Thank you.
I got to ask her like,
am I in Google land?
Like are you guys really
glory?
Cause you know,
you're like kind of famous out there and whether you realize it or not,
you hold an incredible amount of influence.
You really do.
We're going to talk about that.
How many of you want to change your
career trajectory in some way?
Raise your hand.
How many of you want to change your personal trajectory in some way?
How about your legacy trajectory that you want to leave in some way?
And how many of you wouldn't raise your hands no matter what I said?
Pretty good.
So great to be here.
Thank you.
Danielle and Stephanie Reid Hoffman,
who's actually a on our advisory board for girls in the impacts that she's
awesome.
Yeah,
she's a Googler in New York.
Um,
so if you don't mind,
I'd love to start when you were young,
um,
this idea that you decided to go get a job at the motel made at the age of 14.
What on Earth inspired you to do that and to do that job?
You know,
I,
uh,
my mom found herself single when I was five years old and she was single with no
formal education,
uh,
three little kids,
one,
four and five.
And uh,
she had to work two full time jobs as a waitress to make ends meet.
And I sort of that that had a huge impact on me.
And when I was 12 years old riding home from school one day on my navy blue
Schwinn bike,
I sort of had this epiphany and it was,
you know,
sort of a vision,
a vision that um,
three things became really clear at,
which was I wanted my own financial independence.
I wanted to have a big impact and I had this sense because nobody was there for
my mom,
that it was all up to me and that I was going to have to pull myself up by the
boot trout straps.
So I was really focused on trying to make something of myself and I didn't care
what it took.
I was,
I wanted to put myself through college.
And so that was the job down the road.
And at least I can say,
can make a bed the holiday inn way.
So we still do it.
That's awesome.
I mean,
I completely resonate with the idea of financial independence.
That was very early driver for me as well.
Um,
and you know,
as I just mentioned,
I've found myself kinda jumping around trying to find that thing that's gonna
generate interest but also have a huge impact and also help my pocketbook.
Yeah.
Um,
so when you're deciding to make these shifts,
like how do you know when it's the right time?
Yeah,
it's really hard,
right?
I mean,
sometimes you're forced to make a shift.
Um,
and,
and I hear a lot of that from some people,
but you know,
an interesting story,
I used to work in California government for Governor Jerry Brown,
sister Kathleen Brown.
And uh,
she was running for governor and I,
and I was suppressed secretary and I sort of had an Aha moment and I thought,
know I could spend
the rest of my career promoting somebody else's ideas or I could develop my own
ideas.
And it was a moment where I sort of,
and I think this is really important for all of you,
is to look at the path you're on is the path you're on going to get you to where
you want to go.
And at that point I sort of decided,
you know what,
I think I'll be pigeonholed if I stay in state government too long.
I thought it would.
So I moved into the financial industry.
And then the other thing that I think is really important in deciding like when
do you make that change is looking at trends and data.
And so kind of fast forward a little bit,
I was in business school and working full time at a large bank and I was
noticing a lot of data and trends and those trends at the time where that uh,
women were building wealth but they were not going to places like Yahoo finance
to invest their money.
And I sort of had an Aha and a in short developed this idea for women's
financial network,
which,
which the first a financial site for women.
My boyfriend at the time though said,
you know Jen,
I mean it's really good idea,
but like Tarrel Schwab could come in and like take you over tomorrow.
And he was sort of right about that.
But I thought,
you know what,
they're not doing it now.
I got my business plan in hand.
I had started to form a team and I was like,
you know what?
I'm going to go for it.
And it completely changed the trajectory of my career.
I was working at a financial firm at the time and the,
my boss invites me over for dinner.
Um,
you know,
whole different thing.
I mean I felt like all of a sudden I had climbed like 10 runs up the career
ladder.
I ended up doing a book becoming Microsoft money spokesperson if completely
changed my career.
So what I would say is look at the path you're on.
Is it getting you where you want to go?
Is it building this kinds of skills that you want?
Getting you the kind of connections that you want,
giving you the credibility that you need to move forward.
And then also think about the data or trends taking place.
I think it's really important to stay at the forefront and then there's a little
gut that comes into play there.
Yeah,
yeah.
But all that can be pretty darn stressful,
right?
I mean it can be stressful.
They say that what the top stress makers are getting married,
moving and changing her career maybe.
So how do you manage all that?
Well,
you know,
it's,
it's really tough,
right?
I mean,
I actually had an experience where I sort of adopted a philosophical approach.
So a long time ago when I worked for another elected official as I was kind of
coming out of Ucla,
um,
I got a job there when it got close to a job as the assistant press secretary
for then Mayor Tom Bradley of La,
very famous mayor.
And they basically told me I had the job and I went back to my day job and I'm
still wrapping up college.
And uh,
they called me up and they say,
do you know what?
Sorry.
But the mayor wants more diversity on the team.
Actually.
Completely got it.
I was a woman,
but he wanted really more diversity and it was kind of okay.
And so I sat back and then a couple months later I ended up getting through the
boss at the time connection to ultimately become the press secretary to Kathleen
round,
governor Jerry Brown's sister.
And at the age of 25 that was an amazing opportunity.
And so I really now feeling,
and some of those comes from age,
that things happen at the right time for a reason and it's really easy to get
impatient.
And so I know still to this day,
I will force myself to breathe and say,
you know,
the time of when the right opportunities there,
it's going to happen.
But it's also important to keep yourself out there and open to those
opportunities.
Yeah,
I mean you've done such an amazing job in which is
really evident in your book where she's interviewed,
you know,
hundreds of highly,
highly influential people all over the world.
Um,
how did you build your influence and your personal brand so that you could have
these interviews and really
gain those insights and connections.
So I think credibility is so important,
especially here in the valley.
And I saw the power of that when I worked in government for Kathleen because you
know,
there was sort of considered the Kennedys or the west coast and the media and,
and,
and so I saw the influence of media.
And then when I was starting to build my first company and I had just a business
plan in hand,
I went to then ultimately ended up meeting with the CEO of CBS MarketWatch
financial site in town.
And,
uh,
I had this idea and a long story short,
he wasn't willing to invest in it,
but he said,
you know,
why don't you become our women in money columnist?
And I scratched my hand.
I thought,
oh my gosh,
another thing to do.
How am I going to do this?
But I thought,
you know,
it's going to give me some credibility is I'm out building this business,
uh,
I'm going to do that.
And um,
and so there's so much power in credibility.
But the other piece of it,
there's a couple of other pieces is number one is having a niche focus.
Look at yourself and the expertise that you have that's really unique to you and
build off that.
I mean,
everybody has that and trust me,
I've had to go through exercises with myself to really think about like,
what is it that I know?
For me it's the nexus of finance,
technology and women,
I would say,
right?
Because somewhat unique.
So look at that.
And then the other is don't underestimate the power of confidence because a lot
of people,
no matter what level you're at,
you might think,
oh,
I'm not good enough.
I can't,
I can't be talking to see you,
I'm not,
whatever.
But if you don't deliver a message with confidence,
you're never going to go any place.
You all know something extremely well.
You wouldn't be here working if you didn't.
I don't care what area it is,
content marketing,
digital data analytics.
And so when you present something,
the power of presenting it with authority and credibility,
it will make all the difference in your ability to move forward.
The last thing is that I do,
and I've had to learn this.
I mean,
I came from completely,
nothing is drawing,
pulling in those threads that build that credibility foundation for you.
So like,
you know,
there've been times when I'm talking to somebody or wanting to form a
partnership or whatever and I built an advisory board with some name people to
give me that credibility.
So people said,
Oh yeah,
that's,
you know,
that's interesting to me.
So those are um,
uh,
some ways that you know,
you can do that.
The last thing that's worth mentioning is connecting with people on a personal
level.
It doesn't matter who you're talking to,
CEO,
janitor,
whatever.
Everybody is a person.
And sort of a good example is back to when I was building women's financial
network and wanting to connect with very influential people to endorse it or
whatever.
When was Debbi fields of Mrs. Fields cookies.
And the reason she kind of pro came back is that she saw what happened with her
mother,
couldn't even balance a checkbook and she was dealing with her own daughter.
So that personal connection,
no matter who you're talking to,
pitching,
building relationships,
wanting to form a partnership,
honestly I think comes down to that personal connection almost more than
anything.
Mm.
Yeah,
that's great advice.
I mean,
given that I came from the new space and I know how finicky media can be,
you know,
you,
you say it as if it's so easy to get pension,
Amelia,
but how do you know,
how do you do that?
Like,
how did you do what,
how did you get someone to say,
yes,
Jennifer,
we'll have you on CNN or how did you get on Oprah or Howard
and things building upon things so that I also Shuja believe,
believe in the power of boy,
there's so many good examples and we'll talk about one a little bit later,
but,
um,
when something happens is to build upon,
I mean,
a few examples would be,
for example,
uh,
when Martha Stewart was going through her crisis,
I had a really kind of interesting message.
I said,
you know what,
like despite what she has or has not done,
she has still delivered products,
uh,
of great value that,
that everyday people can use.
I think she might w with scan this crisis and I went on CNN,
the next thing and I was doing live shots.
And the next thing is like Fox and the other media are seeing that here in
silicon valley.
When I was here,
actually what happened is I got profiled in the San Francisco Chronicle and I
had been thinking about a book and the agent said,
you know what,
now we've got that profile,
we can take it to the publisher.
They like seeing it cause its credibility and oh and you also have a company.
And then that led to a lot of other things and also understanding how to tell a
good story helped or how to communicate.
Um,
in my case it was educating people about finances.
So when I started building this company,
you know,
I sort of said,
gosh,
I want to help build our brand,
but I don't want to spend gazillions of money like a lot of companies do.
Sometimes I think not so wisely.
I thought,
you know,
I'm going to try to position us as the authority on women and money.
You know,
I'm not bad on TV,
I'm not gray,
done a little bit,
but I'm really,
what's it not as good as a lot of other people.
And I tried it and when I went on good enough to be asked back on.
And so all of that created this and then,
and then what happened?
Then a Cycore soft then because I was out in the media,
then Microsoft saw me out there and they wanted to do a campaign across the
country educating women about money and they came to me and I worked for them
for three years.
So it was really finding that that niche,
that unique today and then getting the one media outlet to pick you up and then
start generating interest with other outlets once you use your ability to pick
up a trend.
And then that leads to so many new opportunities.
I mean it's,
it's,
it's really smart.
And the couple of the things you guys can do,
and I talked about people,
so let's say you have a particular niche and you have something to say because
there's so many interesting trends going on.
You could write a byline,
you could partner with somebody of great authority at another organization and
do a byline.
Then you can take that byline and take it to a media outlet.
Truth be told though,
meet his a lot harder today than it was 10 years ago.
Yeah.
Especially the state of everything right now.
It's so,
it's so different to get your message out and so I wouldn't discount,
yeah.
Some of the big influencers on social media channels as well and events.
So I think a lot of us,
I don't know if I can speak for everybody,
but um,
at some point have been interested in starting something,
whether that be a nonprofit or a company of our own one day.
But making the shift from a major corporation to starting your own business just
seems so overwhelming.
How did you make this shift?
How did you,
what was the thing that sort of helped you to make that transition?
Yeah,
I think,
um,
I think it's really important to have a plan before you make a leap.
Um,
I see people who don't think through the basic thing so clearly like a business
plan,
but also what I mean that I think can make a difference if you're going to make
a change,
let's say,
is to have a team with you.
I mean,
one of the lessons I learned that led to that book is don't go it alone.
I sort of,
for too much of my career actually,
when it alone and I learned,
and that's again why I did the book I learned and looking at really wealthy
people were financially successful people,
whether it's Mark Zuckerberg or Bill Gates or Oprah,
you think from the media that they did it all by themselves,
but they really didn't.
They had a core partner in there with them.
And then they leverage their networks to extend externally.
And by the way,
those folks do leverage their networks more than other people and women tend to
not leverage their networks and relationships as much as as men believe it or
not.
Um,
so when making the leap,
I think,
you know,
one way to think about it is you want to build a moat around so that your as in
a steady a foundation as possible and ways that you can do that is having a team
having a deal in hand.
I could give it an example too of when I was at Bank of uh,
bank one actually I knew I wanted to start another venture and I had an idea for
some kind of versions of,
of quicken software,
but a little more simplified for consumers.
And I had started building this budget kit and before I left I went to the
credit card division.
I said,
you know what,
I'm,
I'm going to try to get a deal on hand to like market,
distribute.
My products are there and I did.
So I would leave with things in place.
I would never like if you need funding for your venture,
I would never leave without funding in place.
I would try to have a dealer to enhance,
I would have a core team and I would make sure that your team doesn't look and
reflect just like you because you want somebody who can go into those other
areas or bring those other skills that you don't have.
Right.
That's the power of having a team.
Yeah.
So those are a few things.
And then always a plan B.
What if it doesn't work out?
Or what if I decide to,
you know,
stay here and I'm going to go to,
China and take on a role and the what if a lot of people don't think and plan
through the wedding.
I would say how he,
like if you have spouses or friends,
dear friends,
talk that through.
So you were really thinking through,
okay,
if something falls apart,
if it's dual,
a leg of the stool falls,
what's my game plan?
Yeah.
I mean one of the keys that you mentioned in your book is make them want it.
And I think here at Google we have 20% projects and we're trying constantly to
get everybody interested in our new product idea.
Um,
and there's of course with physical products,
you can get those out in the market and you can test them,
which you talk a lot about in your book.
But one thing that I've struggled with is what if it's a service?
What if it's something like consulting?
Then how do you test what you can offer if it's you that you're off?
Yeah.
So that,
that's a good one.
Actually.
I've had some friends from some big companies right here come to me on that very
issue,
but I'm going to use,
Mario is a good example.
So Mario headed up,
um,
quicken money way back in the day.
Okay.
And he did exactly that.
And I think he did it the right way.
She ultimately,
what his business is,
is outsourced web development.
But in South America,
when you were thinking about making a change,
and particularly in consulting,
because there,
there's so many people out there,
there are people leaving Mckinsey to start up consulting business and
technology.
Right?
That's who you're going up against.
I would think a few things is,
one is is white,
you are delivering really differentiating.
Is it powerful?
I think Mario had that because you know what,
he had lower cost,
English speaking,
same time zone aren't many people were going to a lot of other places,
right?
So definitely a compelling from hand on top of it.
He knows software.
He was doing a Britain to it.
Okay.
So,
um,
have something,
it's gotta be compelling if you want to stay in business.
Secondly,
I would think about bringing really powerful,
uh,
people to your team when you have the strength of the Google name behind you.
It's not that as nearly as difficult as a lot of other people.
So I would,
I believe in the power of brand association.
Like what are some of,
you know,
you want to bring oof to this team,
like caliber.
So then when you go into your pitching business,
I go,
God,
this how this tune,
they've been a Google and they'd been at Mckinsey whatever.
And Oh gosh,
they know data analytics and they built these models and okay,
so that's that.
And then I would test the waters with potential clients and I would actually try
to have a client or two like ready to go.
That's what,
and then you know,
the last is again,
have a plan B.
So,
um,
in your plan,
like you set some clear goals by the first six months,
we need to achieve x and y for this to like make sense for us.
And um,
you know,
I've seen sort of the power of people setting real markers.
Sometimes we sit like small goals,
but you know,
it's recently with a team of people and uh,
with a,
a big global company and you know,
revenue kind of down.
And uh,
this particular team on the,
on a Saturday I had met and,
and they're thinking,
yeah,
you know,
so what should our goal be for this year?
Or it could be 40 million.
They said,
you know what,
that's like,
stretch it.
Let's make 60.
I'm,
I'm picking a number,
but these are the range of numbers.
65 million is our goal.
We're going to go for 65.
They went for 65.
They exceeded it the following year.
They in the hundred million plus in the following year,
their 200 million.
So if they hadn't set those kinds of markers the following years,
they would not have achieved what they achieved.
Right.
They wouldn't up.
So it's the power of thinking big.
I really loved the power of thinking big,
even here at Google and you know,
in one of my roles,
um,
I remember thinking like,
I'm going to focus and you've,
you know,
you've,
you've moved all her,
the advice of focusing,
but I was,
it's actually,
it was right before I started women's financial network.
I was working at another financial firm after Bank of America.
Really Great.
Loved it.
And uh,
but I had this idea,
but I also thought when I went to that for,
I was like,
you know what I,
I'm going to achieve,
I'm going to focus on two or three big rocks that are gonna make a difference.
It's really easy to get caught up in the minutia all day.
It's really easy.
But if you move one or two big rocks,
like it gets noticed.
And that goes back to building your personal brand and increasing your work.
Like,
and I know you guys have a chance for projects here in innovation,
like if you led something like your,
uh,
your vet.
Yeah.
We have a thing here called Okr is,
and I feel like they can always end up being 50 lines long.
So consolidating that to just what are the top three things that you really want
to focus on is something that I feel like we all could work on and then stay
focused.
Yeah.
And I ended up doing,
getting a deal.
Long story short
is this company has an index,
kind of like the s and p 500 index,
but it really measures the whole market.
Nobody knew about.
Long story short,
it ended up doing a deal with CNBC to use it on TV.
I'm not,
and I never said anything to anybody,
you know,
uh,
keep it quiet until you know,
things are buttoned up.
And that was a really big wind.
The CEO even years later would,
you know,
remember that.
So focusing on the big kills when you have the strength of Google,
like you all do.
Yeah.
There is a piece of advice that you gave in your book,
um,
with,
you know,
my,
Angela was one of the contributors and you know,
you had said this is something that really resonated with you and gave you sort
of the,
the ability to go out there and meet anyone.
What was,
what was that advice that you just,
that really stuck with you?
Wait,
her advice.
Maya Angelo.
Yeah.
You know,
she said,
um,
that,
the people should not look at themselves no less than the CE.
Oh.
And no greater than the babysitter home.
She pays,
but truly an equal person.
And I think maybe more importantly,
she said that,
you know,
there's a way that you walk into a room,
it's not that they're,
you're so braggadocious she said,
but there's a way that you carry yourself with some Felicity,
some warmth,
warmth,
and people feel like I can be okay with this person.
And so the example would be,
and I don't know if some of you have had had it with leaders and,
and I've had to learn it but,
but it makes you feel kind of powerful is you know,
working with CEOs and when you really know what you're talking about and you say
it with authority because they are looking for good advice themselves by the
way,
they can't do it all.
They will listen and they will then come to rely on you and they'll come back.
And so it's like taking a breath,
getting in your power.
And I've used the power of visualization a lot in my life.
A lot.
We could talk about that.
But
yeah,
I mean I,
I'd actually love to go there for a moment because I think a lot of people,
and you had mentioned this in your book,
have this mantra that of the sort of say to themselves or this thing that just
changes their entire presence in a meeting or while they're talking to a
business leader or you have that pitch that you're trying to make.
Like,
what is your process and how,
what tips can you give to people to develop what they can use in those moments?
So I'm going to go to,
I'll give you like a really good example.
So after I sold my company here,
um,
I was thinking about what I wanted to do next.
I figured I'd start something again,
wasn't quite sure.
I thought,
you know what,
maybe I'll work at a large company.
I ended up,
uh,
pitching Jamie diamond,
who was then the CEO.
He's the CEO of JP Morgan Chase now pitching him,
uh,
exploring working with him.
He was the CEO of bank one at the time and I ended up getting a meeting with him
and I'm sitting there like,
and now I was prepared.
We'll get into the,
in the second.
And,
uh,
I was just thinking,
am I going to say what I'm going there?
Right.
But in all honesty,
my suggestions are,
number one is to always do your homework and know something about the person.
I think,
um,
there's so much power and making a personal connection with somebody.
And you can do that by,
um,
there's a lot you can find online.
You can pick up something in an office and it can tell you a lot and you can
start from a conversation from there.
Um,
I like to,
you know,
when I'm,
somebody recently was looking for advice,
she's looking for a promotion in her,
uh,
in her company actually.
And she,
she needs to sell herself more.
And I said,
you know,
what I would do is a one pager that very clearly and someone visually,
not a bunch of texts,
crystallizes your brand and the impact you've had here.
And she did this,
did that,
and then go have conversations with all the key stakeholders.
And she's doing that right now.
So back to my meeting,
I ended up having a one pager on some specific ideas to build the business that
of course,
leverage what I knew.
So that's the other,
um,
the other thing and then the last is,
to try to offer something of value to somebody when you're meeting with them.
And you know,
one is sort of depends on the situation,
but in a lot of cases it can be as simple as looking on linkedin at the
connection points that you have and having a conversation where at some point
you're saying,
gosh,
do you know so and so at such and such company?
And they'll say,
no.
He said,
you know,
what would you like me to introduce you?
People like to do that.
Uh,
they,
they appreciate that.
Um,
and then lastly is,
you know,
you've picked up some personal things or things in that meeting with somebody,
anything from their,
uh,
their dislikes to personal items to things they share.
Remember that or Tuck it away as I do and include something personal and a
followup note.
I think it makes a big difference.
Like I really liked it when you said that it really stood out or you know,
I think one of the things that could help you move the needle on such and such
that you talked about was that,
uh,
that it makes a difference in your ability to connect with that person and then
to come back to them later.
If you need to,
to get to your point about how many people want to leave a legacy to Jennifer's
company,
has working with a bunch of girls trying to help develop them into future female
leaders.
Um,
so what are some of the things that you think are critical to developing in our
youth to really propel women to the top?
Well,
you know,
look at it.
You can't open the newspaper without reading about,
you know,
future of work,
getting everybody ready for AI and cryptocurrency and all this stuff.
Diversity,
talent pipeline.
And it's strange that,
you know,
here we are today and only 6% of CEOs are women.
So we want to change that.
And oddly,
while there's a lot of stuff in the stem and coding space,
when you at entrepreneurship or business,
there isn't anything that equips teen girls in this case to actually build those
skills.
And so over 12 weeks they go through a mini Mba.
They do it afterschool,
we offer it year round,
and they go from ideation to an actual business plan and they're launching
ventures.
We just made,
one of them made international headlines,
uh,
the other,
a couple of weeks ago.
Um,
so we're moving the needle in their confidence in giving them a leg up
scholarships,
but at the same time allowing people like you to really,
my hope is that all of you will join us in creating the next generation of real
leaders,
um,
and playing a role in that with us because you can do it on a personal level.
I mean,
there's so many different ways to,
to be involved,
but it's been incredibly exciting what these girls are doing.
Yeah.
It's really awesome.
Companies like Google to who are looking to build,
you know,
a talent pipeline,
um,
this is really important.
And to take what they're learning in stem,
you know,
they can't take what they're learning in stem or coding if they don't have the
business or entrepreneurship skills to create companies and jobs.
[inaudible] well,
thank you.
Um,
I'd now like to turn to the audience if anybody has any questions for Jennifer.
Perfect.
So from Emily and tech corners,
uh,
sometimes the power of confidence of delivery outweighs the power of expertise
or skill.
Have you run into that before?
If so,
how do you manage?
So I have been in those roles.
So two things that I do.
One is there have been moments where I've taken somebody advice and I just go
get in your power and I stand up tall.
One time when I was hosting some shows,
the producer of the guy said,
you know,
uh,
some advice that he had gotten was to,
um,
love your audience.
And I think there's real power and putting a smile on your face.
It just puts you in the mood.
I think dressing the role actually can give you a lot of confidence,
um,
much more so than you might give credit.
I mean,
it has for me.
And the last thing is the power of visualization.
So I want to share kind of a fun story is I uh,
uh,
you know,
had a little bit of TV background and when I was really young it was sort of a
kind of what I thought was a dream job.
At long story short,
I ended up getting called by CBS TV and La to come in for an audition,
um,
tomorrow to be there live money expert on TV tomorrow.
Now it's like,
oh my God,
I haven't done this in a year.
And like,
and I'm not really that good and oh my gosh,
but you know,
it'd be cool.
So I get on the phone,
I said,
uh,
can we do this Thursday?
And like I need to buy time.
I was like,
oh my gosh.
And then I just said,
you know what,
because this was kind of like my dream.
I said,
you are going to get this,
you are going to get this.
And I just focused and I was like,
I am pulling out the stops to get this and I'm just going to focus and I'm going
to live her.
And I visualize myself and [inaudible] actually that little experience I shared
when I was 12 years old,
the epiphany really was a visualization about impacting people on a large scale.
I ended up going into this station,
I'm next to the TV anchor I grew up with.
You know,
how weird is that?
Right?
And it's after the morning show and they're like,
okay,
let's do a dry run Jana.
And you know,
I'll see if chicken [inaudible] and,
and so do we do a dry run as okay and okay,
we're,
we're tape is rolling real life and we do the shtick.
I'm talking about money and you know,
it was out of the park and you sort of know that.
So I really think you have to visualize yourself and I,
I've seen this countless times.
Visualize yourself delivering it or speaking with the picture yourself doing
that.
And then,
um,
and then
right.
Go in and do it.
I mean this,
it's sort of similar to another theme in the book that really resonated.
So I'm going to jump in with one more question.
Um,
but you talk about redefining your comfort zone.
and what I found so interesting is,
you know,
everybody says,
take a leap,
take the leap,
just go do this thing.
But it's not really taking that big of a leap.
Right?
You're still what you,
I'd love to hear sort of what your spiel on it because I thought it was,
yeah.
And I,
you know,
so first off,
45% of millionaires experienced fear and two thirds of them though yet said that
they had to move outside their comfort zones in order to,
uh,
build their financial success.
Right?
It just makes sense.
You can't,
you can't stay where you are and get to where you want to go.
You cannot stay where you are and get to want to go where you can't to um,
our friends have the expertise and not deliver it with confidence.
You're holding yourself back.
Why?
There's nothing to be afraid.
Like we hold ourselves back.
And so one way when you're making a change is to realize you're never going to
something completely unfamiliar.
You're almost always leveraging your skillset.
Uh,
it could be a network that's around you.
It could be some people that are working with you that you work with before
there's some familiarity to it.
Um,
and then the last thing is in the book there's a story about Tricia rain where
she was at a school teacher actually made like $100,000,
but she had this cosmetics business on the side and she wanted to make the leap
and she was kind of nervous about it.
And she had a couple kids and she had this Aha moment and she said she was
afraid of losing her paycheck.
Right?
Make sense,
right?
And she said,
you know,
but I'm actually not really guaranteed a paycheck.
I have to show up every day and I have to do it.
And there's lots of ways.
I just had a conversation this weekend with a good friend who has sold two
companies,
a women,
she has a young child,
so she's decided she intentionally wants to keep things ramped down.
But her,
her innovative mind has two other business ideas.
So what she's gonna do is she's going to prep them to take to other companies
for them to run with and she might get a licensing piece of it or help them get
it off the ground or something.
Good idea,
way of staying in what she's doing.
Um,
but still being able to maybe see your ideas come to life,
which you can do to some extent.
It Google.
Yeah.
I mean getting creative about the things you're not great at and using what you
are great at it that I,
when looking back at some of the changes I've made successfully,
it were all,
it was all things that weren't huge leaps that I was doing something that I had
already been doing before.
Um,
and the thing is I didn't go so well.
I tried to make too far of a leap and that's kind of where things go wrong.
So there was the first time I'd ever heard it crystallized in that way.
Um,
any other questions in the audience?
So first and foremost,
thank you so much for joining us today.
My question is around comfort zones.
As we talked about when we speak on wealth generation,
people look at that and they look at millionaires and billionaires and think,
wow,
that must've taken a long time or they had a very innovative idea and how do
they get in that space?
What would you say to people who are looking to build wealth or become more
financially sound but see it's so far off in the distance that they're kind of
stuck in place if you will like their caution to move and they think,
oh,
it's such a long journey and I have to do so much to get there.
Yeah,
so it's a great question.
Um,
I think people,
I've seen people can get there faster than you think.
So two examples.
Big story over this past weekend about people who had become millionaires in
their thirties and they made a conscious decision because they wanted to live a
different life.
So I basically didn't want to be beholden.
And um,
they,
there's,
there's so many ways that you can live below your means.
I did it.
I mean,
I was always about living below your means because every time you're spending
money it's,
it's going to somebody else and not yourself in the power of compounding that
over the years.
Um,
there's definitely things like completely taking advantage of your 401k whenever
you come across any kind of windfall or extra money.
Like tacking it aside all the time.
Um,
I got lucky when I sold my company.
Well,
not lucky.
I paid attention is,
you know,
made some money and really thought about how it was going to grow it and I put
it in real estate and tripled it and five year literally tripled it in five
years.
Um,
the other really interesting story is that my stepfather found himself
completely out of money at like about 60.
He had never saved generation,
hadn't learned.
He started his own business and it was about to get a contract with the city of
La.
And Long Story Short,
uh,
didn't get that contract probably because of some other political stuff.
And uh,
do you know what to do?
And I actually ended up moving in with my parents and,
and I was actually in business school at the time and I sort of feel like,
you know,
there's a,
there was a reason I was living down in that area and,
um,
he reinvented himself,
which is something that everybody has to be continuously at the forefront.
He amazingly learn like cad skills,
all the software,
Internet.
I mean,
here's a guy who was 60 and this is like 10 years ago.
I mean it was really impressive.
And then when he had nothing,
so then he ended up getting high.
He's an engineer by background that since he's an engineer for like,
um,
public facilities and stuff and he ended up getting hired by a solid
construction company that's been around many years and he ended up putting aside
like a half million dollars and not that long a time.
And they still had,
you know,
a fairly normal lifestyle.
They had to make a big shift and a change.
Um,
but,
but you know,
it's okay.
Like we,
the world makes us feel like we have to be living large.
I could care less about having a bigger,
and I don't have a big house by the way,
actually don't want a bigger house but,
but um,
there is some confidence and freedom that really comes from putting it aside and
feeling in control.
And um,
if you're,
if you're a married like having conversations about,
and I did this very regularly.
In fact,
every year I set my own plan.
I,
I've,
I've done this for probably 20 years and I used to do with back day wrote it up
like buddy system.
But every year at the beginning of the year,
I always think about my goals for the year and I,
and I lay him out from a financial perspective,
career and personal,
including,
you know,
building friends or networks.
Cause I haven't been doing that and I know it's important.
I want to share the Alex story cause it's a really great one.
So this past weekend,
this friend of mine is at my house and uh,
I said,
Gosh Jyzelle she just,
kids are with their kids.
Gosh,
just so you know,
my husband and I were kind of talking like,
it's very interesting,
you know,
we have dinner parties with people over,
but people don't reciprocate a whole lot.
And she says,
you know,
genuinely share something.
When I was married to Alex and Alex is 49 right now,
nice looking guy.
She works for a hedge fund.
We lived in a 7,000 square foot house.
He made great money and I said,
Alex,
why don't we have your team over?
Why don't we have the analysts over?
We have this house,
like what are we paying for it?
And he just wasn't comfortable with it.
He was like an introvert.
He lost his job.
It is three years later and he now has verbally recognized the shortfall of just
failing to reach out.
And I want to go to something about networking too,
which is rather than feeling,
oh,
I've got a network,
I got to do this,
I would,
I would take a different twist to it.
I would view it as,
I'm like,
I just want to have good impact in the world.
I,
you know,
I want to talk to this person,
see if I can be helpful in some way and impart what I,
and by the way,
I learned so much back now from people I used to sit on an airplane.
I would maybe not be so open,
but you pick up so much and opening yourself to the possibilities of what's
around you,
um,
can take you to where you want to go internally and externally.
Yeah,
I mean so much more to talk.
I know what you were saying earlier,
totally reminded me of mom's advice where she had said everything you buy owns a
part of you.
Um,
and you know it when you said save and you,
you don't have a large house.
I think that that constricts you and might reduce your confidence to take that
step.
So having that safety net really does impact your ability to maneuver in ways
cause you,
you know,
you have a cushion.
I just have very quick question about identifying your niche,
about you,
define your niche.
If you can give us some guidance about how you did it,
then I need any advice on that.
You know,
if you know the space you're in,
and I would kind of imagine all of you do because you,
you're like in it,
by the way,
the best ideas and businesses and stuff come from like your experience.
You,
you stumble across something.
So your niche,
like for me it was,
I really sort of step back,
um,
you know,
I have done grids before.
It was like,
okay,
but if I were boiling it down to the three things that are really me that are
unique,
so I want them to be unique,
compelling,
and like kind of at the forefront of where trends in industry is going,
right so much now is like data and AI and automation and,
uh,
what else?
People and talent.
I mean,
it's right.
So,
um,
but there's so many food is going in all sorts of different places,
crazy different places.
So,
so I would,
I would literally crystallize it to three words that define the space that you
know and that you're good at and that,
um,
whether there's value to be had in the market.
So like an overlap between a trend that's happening,
it's something that you're really good at.
Yes.
Yeah.
Does that make sense?
And then the other way to think about it too is if you were going to write an
article right now in the New York Times or the Wall Street Journal and you were
going to like,
leverage what,
you know,
what would you write about?
What would the headline be and what would you talk about?
And I bet your three themes should be like,
you know,
there'll be floating in there.
Right.
Interesting.
I heard you say to start it off with a maid or euro 14.
I was,
how did you,
I guess,
go from that situation to like,
even knowing to go on a river?
Yeah,
that's a really good,
you know,
I mean,
I feel so blessed today.
I mean I really,
because,
um,
so when I'm having my bad days,
I,
you know,
God,
like I,
you know,
I could have been in a very different situation.
I,
you know,
there's power in education and that's why we do girls with impact because I feel
like if I didn't go to college and even business school really changed my
thinking to a whole more sophisticated level,
change my income like that too.
For most people it does.
And it changes your ability to operate with people on a higher plane,
sort of,
um,
you know,
you can sort of argue business school,
there's so much.
But you know,
um,
and I think watching and paying attention to a lot of people.
So small little example and I just pulling something,
you know,
long time ago,
I remember when I was working in politics and a lawyer we worked with and he had
written a book on going to meetings and I read that book and something really
stood with me,
which is now whenever I go to a meeting,
I jot down like,
what do I want to come away with?
And even if I'm going to get rejected,
which like I've been rejected a gazillion times,
it hurts,
but I know it's going to happen.
And I just like,
I,
you know,
hope for the best and prepare for the worst is I still try to come out of
something with that meaning and that could be,
um,
a,
a relationship with them because you know what,
that person has a gazillion relationships themselves.
Okay.
And that's happened before I met with somebody,
a VC guy,
and he introduced me to somebody else.
Um,
it could be that they're going to introduce you to somebody.
Okay.
You don't have,
you know,
that's great.
You know,
by the way we do.
Do you think there's somebody like I'm meeting here with folks about girls with
impact and um,
I'm having that very conversation because it's a really small world.
Like it's a crazy small world and you never know who you're going to bump into.
Um,
so,
you know,
back to question,
it's like,
it's watching people wanting to do something bigger.
And I,
you know,
it's a combination of luck.
I think it was also partly intentionally looking at the big picture,
the trends and feeling like,
you know,
I think we can be an authority in the space.
Cause I see the trends.
There is no authority on women and money.
They're making more money.
Everybody cares about women.
They're writing the checks.
By golly maybe I have something I'm not great but maybe it will be good enough.
And I knew the strategy of how to come up with a good story,
a good angle and so I'd go on and I was good enough that they,
so things feed on themselves.
And I guess I would say like no matter where you're going is
actually,
we talked about this is the power of telling a good story,
a good whatever it is,
succinctly,
not too long visually when it makes sense.
The visual identity of girls within back,
the guy who did that made all the difference in the world.
Like it's the difference between looking like you have a product and your
professional versus something else.
Buying somebody if you need to like put your best foot forward.
Um,
yeah I love that.
So we'll take one more question.
The board skill development
in the personal life for the Korean,
there's so many skills you need to learn and then given
a time we don't have too much time in a day.
No.
So how do we choose the best skill that is most important to us and how do we
strategize to ensure that we are not missing up in some other skill that may
later be important and we may end up in some issues.
This is a big issue that I face.
Yeah,
that's a really good.
So how do you develop the best skill given that you have limited time,
right?
To keep yourself current and moving forward.
I mean,
I mean I'm going to come back to it more crystal,
but even like with girls within pack from me,
you know I was in Davos in and saw the trends and and felt like,
you know,
this also keeps me personally at the forefront of innovation and where things
are headed.
So for you I would be thinking,
I would be looking at what,
what do I actually liked doing?
I think he got a really like what you're doing because forget it.
So,
and then I would force herself to narrow it down to like three to five of those.
I really like these.
Then I would probably look at,
okay where's the,
where are the trends going?
Like the skills that are going to be in demand.
And you could,
well you might know that off the top of your head,
you could look at where,
uh,
Google is placing a money and training or looking to buy up companies.
That's the way of doing that,
right?
To our company.
Okay.
Yeah.
Too,
too hardcore.
We search reports,
right.
Um,
or where money is going.
So like cryptocurrency is a big example.
Um,
that would be sort of the other way I would look at doing it.
And then I would think like,
um,
you could even have a conversation with somebody like,
you know,
senior law.
Like could you apply,
could you,
could you develop a skill and apply it to something that would be a value here?
Like in a new effort.
That's kind of interesting cause what does that do?
You build your skill,
you increase your value potentially here and you increase kind of your potential
monetary earning potential.
Um,
and then hopefully it's kind of the skill that's in demand.
But,
uh,
yeah,
I think the overlap with,
you know,
you really have to like it,
it's,
it's such a key you have to like really enjoy it.
Like if you love mob,
you know,
I got to share this,
this is great.
And then we'll wrap it.
But my,
I ha I had this young woman from another country who,
um,
you know,
it's a great story a bit and she ended up working for me.
She works with my husband now and she has her cough colleague who frankly
doesn't really speak much English.
Okay.
But she is a math wizard.
I mean they,
they,
and by the way,
the CEO of this company,
it's a division of a large company.
I mean,
very sophisticated.
They have seen nothing of what this girl has pulled together.
Allowing them to see competitors and where money is going is unbelievable.
So like for example,
that is a great example.
Like if you were like a genius in one particular place,
Andrew liked it.
I would explore that.
And they go where the future demand or the trends are going with things that
we're,
and we read about
in the headlines.
Yeah.
Double down on the thing that you're good.
I've been in Sony teams where other people are more passionate maybe in a
particular area and there is no way you can compete.
Right.
Cause they're talking to their friends about that subject and the evenings
they're doing something about it on the weekends and here you are just trying to
recover from the week.
Right.
So having that thing that you're interested in is so,
yeah.
So helpful.
And so it set a marker again even for that.
So,
okay,
it's not going to be in the next two months maybe,
but over the next year,
each quarter I'm going to do x or I want to get a certificate and acts or you
know,
if Google is really like was just say they were covering something or they
wanted something,
maybe you know,
um,
it,
it can make a difference in putting you into a different role having a certain
skillset.
Yeah,
definitely.
Well thank you so much for joining us.
I really appreciate it.
If people here on the live shame aren't youtube want to get involved with girls
without talking?
They do.
So I want and need all of you to join us with girls with impact please.
Boys and girls,
like whether you look at,
we are all in this together so you can either just help amplify what we're
doing.
Please go to girls with him,
but we're going to send out an email.
Yeah,
you can play a role in supporting a girl to go through the training.
You could also,
if you want,
mentor a girl and we keep it pretty flexible,
not heavy duty because people are all over the place.
Um,
but it's a great way to have a personal legacy and to really join us in
hopefully having a really big legacy.
I hope you all will.
Thank you,
Jennifer.
I really appreciate it.